[Music]
I have to say that I'm very glad to be
here I understand we have over 80
countries here so that's a whole new
paradigm for me to speak to all of these
countries and each country I'm sure you
have this thing called the
parent-teacher conference do you know
what the parent-teacher conference not
the ones for your kids but the one you
had as a child where your parents come
to school and your teacher talks to your
parents and it's little bit awkward
well I remember in third grade I had
this moment where my father who never
takes off from work he's a classical
blue-collar working-class immigrant
person going to school to see his son
how he's doing and the teacher said to
him he said you know John is good at
math and art and he kind of noted you
know the next day I'm talking to a
customer at our tofu store and he said
you know John's good at math and it
always stuck with me all my life why did
dad say art why was in a Nokia why
became a question in my entire life and
that's it right because of being good at
math meant he bought me a computer and
some of you remember the computer this
is my first computer who had an apple to
Apple to user it's very cool
that's remember Apple 2 did nothing at
all you'd plug it in you type it in
green text would come out it would say
you're wrong most the time that was a
computer we knew that computers a
computer that I learned about going to
MIT my father's dream and MIT however I
learned about the computer at all levels
and after I went to art school to get
away from computers and it began to
think about the computer as more of a
spiritual space of thinking and I was
influenced by performance arts so this
is a 20 years ago I made a computer out
of people it was called a human powered
computer experiment I have a power
manager Mouse driver memory etc and I
bought this in Kyoto the old capital of
Japan it's a room broken in two halves
I've turned the computer on and these
assistants are placing a giant floppy
disk with a cardboard and it's put into
the computer
and the floppy disk drive person wears
it she finds the first sector on the
disk and takes data off the disk and
passes it off to of course the bus so
the bus diligently carries the data into
the computer to the memory to the CPU
the vram etc and it's actual working
computer that's the bus really and it
looks kind of fast that's a mouse driver
where's X Y it looks like it happened
kind of quickly but it's actually a very
slow computer and when I realize how
slow this computer was compared to how
fast the computer is it may be wonder
about computers and technology in
general and some talk today about four
things really the first three things are
about how I've been curious about
technology design and art and how they
intersect how they overlap and also a
topic that I've taken on since four
years ago I became the president of
Rhode Island School of Design leadership
and I'll talk about how I look to
combine these four areas and a kind of a
synthesis kind of experiment so starting
from technology technology is a
wonderful thing when that Apple 2 came
out it really could do nothing it could
show text and after we waited a bit we
have these things called images remember
what images were first possible the
computer is gorgeous full-color images
and then after a few years we got CD
quality sound it's incredibly glisten a
sound of the computer and then movies by
a cd-rom it was amazing
remember that excitement and then the
browser appeared browser was great but
the browser's are primitive very narrow
bandwidth Tex first then images we
waited CD quality sound over the net
then movies over the Internet kind of
incredible and then the mobile phone
occurred text images audio video and now
we have iPhone iPad Android with text
video audio so you see this little
pattern here we're kind of stuck in a
loop perhaps and this sense of
possibility
from computing something I've been
questioning for last ten or so years and
have looked to design as we understand
most things and to understand design
without technology has been a passion of
mine and I have a small experiment to
give you a quick design lesson designers
talk about the relationship between form
and content content and form what does
that mean well content is the word up
there fear it's a four-letter word it's
a kind of a bad feeling word fear fear
is set in light Helvetica so it's not
too stressful and if you sit in ultra
light Helvetica it's like a fear who
cares
all right you take the same ultralight
Helvetica make it big like whoa that
hurts
fear so you can see how you change a
scale you change a form content is the
same what use do you feel differently
you change the typeface to like this
typeface it's kind of funny it's like
pirate typeface like Captain Jack
Sparrow type of our fear that's not
fearful it's like really funny or fear
like this they a kind of a nightclub
typeface like we got to go to fear it's
like amazing right it just changes the
same content or you make it
the letters are separate apart they're
huddled together like on the deck of the
Titanic and you feel sorry for the
letters like I feel the fear you feel
for them or you change the typeface to
something like this it's very classy
it's like that that expensive restaurant
fear I can never get in there it's just
amazing fear but that's form content if
you just change one letter in that
content you get a much better word much
better content free free is a great word
you can serve it almost any way free
bold feels like Mandela free it's like
yes I can be free free even light feels
coming ha can breathe in free it feels
great or even free spread out it's like
I can breathe in free so easily and I
can add any blue gradients and a dove
and I have like Don Draper free so you
see that form content design
works that way it's a powerful thing
it's like magical almost like though the
magician's we've seen that at Ted it's
magic design does that and I've been
curious about how design and Technology
intersect I'm going to show you some old
work I never really show anymore
they gave me sets of what I used to do
so yeah so I made a lot of work in the
90s this was a square that responds to
sound people ask me why I made that it's
not clear but I I thought it'd be neat
for the square to respond to me and my
kids were small then and my kids would
play with these things like I you know
they would say daddy yeah like that we
got a computer store they were the same
thing and there was a daddy why does the
computer respond to sound and it was
really at the time I was wondering why
doesn't computer respond to sound so I
made this as a kind of a experiment of
time and then I spent a lot of time in
the space of interactive graphics and
things like this and I I stopped doing
it because my students at MIT got so
much better than myself so I had to hang
up my mouse but in 96 I made my last
piece it was in black and white
monochrome fully monochrome all in
integer mathematics that's called tap
type right it's paying a tribute to the
wonderful typewriter that my mother used
to type on all the time as a legal
secretary it has ten variations this
ship ten variations is just like spin
the in the letter around like a ring of
letters sits 20 years old so it's kind
of a say this is um I love the French
film the red balloon a great movie right
I love that movie so it's sort of like a
play on that it's peaceful
[Applause]
I'm sure this last one this is about
balance you know it's kind of stressful
typing out so if you type on this
keyboard you can like balance it out
if you hit G life's okay so I would say
hit G and it's gonna be alright so now
it's 20 years ago and I was always on
the periphery of art but being president
RISD I've gone deep into art and art is
a wonderful thing fine arts pure art you
know when people say I don't get art I
don't get it all that means
art is working you know it's like
artists supposed to be enigmatic so when
you say like I don't get it like oh
that's great art does that because art
is about asking questions the questions
that may not be answerable and Risley we
have this amazing facility called the
Edna Lawrence Nature lab it has 80,000
samples of animal bone mineral plants
you know in Rhode Island
if a animal gets hit on the road they
call us up when we pick it up and stuff
it and why do we have this facility
because at RISD you have to look at the
actual animal the object to understand
this volume to perceive it and reason
you're not allowed to draw from an image
and many people ask me John could she
just digitize all this make it all
digital wouldn't be better and often say
well there's something good to how
things used to be done there's something
very different about it something we
should figure out what is good about how
we did it even in this new era and I
have a good friend he's a new media
artist named Matata Hasegawa he's based
in London now actually he's in Tokyo but
when he was base in London he had a game
with his wife he would go to antique
shops and the game was as such when we
look at antique we wants we'll ask the
shopkeeper for the story behind the
antique and if it's a good story we'll
buy it so they go to int antique shop
and they look at this cop man so tell us
about this cup and the shopkeeper would
say it's old tell us more oh it's really
old
and you saw over and over the antiques
valley was all about it being old and as
a new media artist he reflected and said
you know I spent my whole criminal art
people say wow your art what is it it's
new media and he realized it isn't about
old or new it's about something in
between
it isn't about old the dirt new the
cloud it's about what is good a
combination of the cloud and the dirt is
where the action is that you see it in
all interesting art today and all
interesting businesses today how we
combine those two together to make good
it's very interesting so art makes
questions and leadership is something
that is asking a lot of questions
we aren't functioning so easily anymore
we aren't we aren't a simple
authoritarian regime anymore
as an example of authoritarianism I was
in Russia one time traveling in
saint-petersburg at a National Monument
and I saw this sign that says do not
walk on the grass and I thought oh I
mean I speak English and you're trying
to single me out that's not fair
but I found a sign for russian-speaking
people and it was the best sign ever to
say no it was like no swimming no hiking
you know anything my favorite ones are
no plants why would you bring a plant to
national monument shirt and also no love
so that is authoritarianism
and what what is that structurally it's
a hierarchy we all know the hierarchy is
how we run many systems today but as we
know it's been disrupted it is now a
network instead of a perfect tree
it's a header our key instead of
hierarchy and that's kind of awkward and
so today leaders are faced with how to
lead differently I believe this is work
I've done my colleague Becky Vermont on
creative leadership what can we learn
from artists and designers for how to
lead because in many senses I regularly
loves to avoid mistakes
someone who's creative actually loves to
learn from mistakes a traditional leader
is always wanting to be right whereas a
creative leader hopes to be right and in
this frame is important today in this
complex ambiguous face and artists and
designers have a lot to teach us I
believe and I had a show in London
recently where my friends invited me to
come to London for four days to sit in a
sandbox and I said great and so I sent a
sandbox for four days straight six hours
every day 6 min employment for anyone in
London and that was really bad but I
would listen to people hear their issues
draw on the sand shore the figure things
out and it was kind of hard to figure
what I was doing you know it's like
always one on one meeting is like four
days and it felt wrong being present
actually well the guy this is my job
president I do lot of some meetings you
know and by the end of the experience I
realized why I was doing this it's
because leaders what we do is we connect
improbable connections and hope
something will happen and in that room I
found so many connections between people
across all of London and so leadership
connecting people is the great question
today whether you're in the hierarchy or
the header are key it's a wonderful
design challenge and one thing I've been
doing is doing some research on systems
that can combine technology and
leadership with an art and design
perspective let me show you something
I've been shown anywhere actually so
what this is is a kind of sketch
application sketch wrote in Python you
know there's like Photoshop this is
called power shop and the way it works
is imagine an organization you know the
CEO isn't ever
at the top to see is that the centered
organization there may be different
subdivisions in the organization you
might want to look into different areas
for instance green or areas doing well
red are areas where poor li you know how
do you as a leader scan connect make
things happen so for instance you might
open up distribution here and find the
different subdivisions in there and know
that you know someone in eco over here
and these people here are an eco the
people you might engage with as CEO
people who wanted to going across the
hierarchy and part of the challenge of
the CEO is to find connections across
areas and so you might look and R&D and
here you see one person who crosses the
two areas of interest and it's a person
important to engage so you might want to
for instance get up ahead to display on
how you're interacting with them how
many coffees do you have how often are
you calling them emailing them what is a
tenor of the email how was it working
out leaders Michael to use these systems
to better regulate how they work inside
the hierarchy you can also imagine using
technology like from luminoso the guys
in Cambridge so we're looking at deep
text analysis what is a tenor of your
communications so these kind of systems
I believe are important they're targeted
social media systems around leaders and
I believe that this kind of perspective
will only begin to grow as more leaders
enter the space of art and design
because our design lets you think like
this find different systems like this
and I just begun thinking like this so
I'm glad to share that with you so in
closing I want to thank all of you for
your attention
thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]